Hello Freak bitches.
I just read this book about the making of the Panama Canal.
And they talk about,
you know,
when the front,
the French first tried to do it,
they went in and the late 19th century and they,
you know,
you gotta think technology in the late 19th century,
they didn't have fucking electricity.
They didn't have shit,
right?
They had giant machines and they were trying to bulldoze a,
a canal through the most dense tropical jungle that you could get through.
And,
and they,
and they lost something like 20% of the people that went down there,
died of malaria and yellow fever,
which are both mosquito borne diseases.
So they go down there and they fight it out for like 10 years.
They keep sending people down to keep dying,
keep sending people down,
keep dying.
And uh,
and even if you don't die,
you're working 14 hour days in jungle heat with a fucking,
with a little spade.
And then all of a sudden they'd get a monster rain and everything you'd
excavated,
there'd be a mudslide.
It would fill it right up again.
They'd start all over.
There were snakes,
there was fucking mountain lions,
and they just finally gave up.
Finally,
France just went,
fuck this.
They had bled hundreds of millions of dollars.
And so and so.
Then the u s stepped in and I go,
we can do it.
So we came in and some guy in had realized that mosquitoes were the problem,
that nobody knew that malaria and yellow fever where mosquito mosquito born for
whatever reason,
they just thought it was fucking popping out out of the dirt.
They thought it was like fumes coming out of the dirt and this guy's like,
no,
it's fucking mosquitoes.
So he came in with a team of like 10 people and they just started in educating
people about how to get rid of mosquitoes,
which is basically get rid of standing water.
And so instead of having mud roads,
they poured concrete.
And uh,
and instead of having open barrels that people collect rainwater and they would
put sheets over them and,
uh,
fucking God,
that's it.
That's all I had to do to stop the mosquitoes.
No deaths from malaria and yellow fever.
After the first couple of years they started construction.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
So they just figured out a way to stop the mosquitoes from breeding without
poison.
Without poison.
That's incredible.
I would have thought they would just agent orange the fuck out of that flows
just standing water.
Wow.
Do you know malaria has killed half the people that have ever died ever?
No Shit.
Wow.
Tasks.
The people that have ever died ever in the history of the human race have died
from malaria and still unabated.
No fucking cure.
My friend,
Justin's got an a three times.
Really?
Where's he live?
Well,
he goes to the Congo.
It makes wells for the pygmies.
Yeah.
Justin wren
catch it and you take the pill right away.
You're fine.
If you
the proper medication,
you will be okay.
But um,
there's a bunch of different strains of malaria and some of them last a long
time and he's had one strain where he got it.
He recovered from it and then he got sick and because he got sick,
the malaria came back.
So he got an unrelated illness without being around the mosquitoes and malaria
came back and he had to figure it out that the malaria had made a relapse.
So He's had it three times,
two times from being bitten one time from a relapse.
So is malaria something that just stays with you for life?
Think with some cases and not just,
not necessarily for life,
but it can recur over the course of a certain amount of years and then your body
eventually gets over it.
But he was saying that one case of malaria,
you can have it for as much as 30 years.
Wow.
And dying of it is about as painful as it gets.
Your brain starts to fucking fry.
You just go crazy.
Your entire body feels like it's made of acid.
It's brutal.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck.
You know,
and you think about how,
you know,
Third World,
how,
you know,
we're trying to,
we're trying to do good in the world.
Malaria is just number one,
two and three that we should be focusing on.
Yeah.
There was some work that they were doing.
Um,
kind of want to say somewhere around California,
someone was doing it where they were trying to figure out a way to engineer a
mosquito that does not get malaria and they were going to release that mosquito.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I heard about this.
Is that what it was?
Well I think it happened with the Zika virus.
The malaria really kill half the people that ever lived get the facts.
Did it?
It's a myth.
Oh it doesn't matter.
It's killer.
It's definitely probably one of the biggest throughout human history.
But to actually know the actual fact,
if it has killed that many people,
it's probably not cause it would have had to kill it at an average of five and a
half,
a million per year.
And for like the last 30 or 40 years,
it's only about two to 3 million.
So that number
pretty good.
30 or 40 years?
At least 20%.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So,
but they don't know.
So where does it come from?
Does any,
does any site support that this site tries to debunk it?
We have to be sure that they're not right.
Cause I feel like I read it from a science paper,
which might not necessarily what click.
We had rob wolf the other day and he thought that the vomitorium was really,
some people make mistakes,
but it's a,
it's killed fuck loads of people.
It's just,
there's a lot of those God damn diseases.
It scared the shit out of you.
Like,
remember when the Ebola craze happened and everybody was panicking that a bullet
had made its way to the United States.
Remember that one lady,
she was a nurse and she was in quarantine and they tried to keep from
quarantine.
She's like,
fuck you.
I'm going shopping.
Like Ooh,
that's right.
Yeah.
You like get your quarantine.
She's like,
I don't have it.
Well the Zika thing is not under under wraps.
They've got it here.
It's down in Florida.
And uh,
I think that they,
I know they were trying to genetically modify mosquitoes for Zika.
Yeah.
I'm a friend of mine.
His wife got pregnant and he wouldn't,
he wouldn't let her go anywhere.
It's like we're there.
We're supposed to go to Hawaii or maybe Mexico or something like that.
And they were like,
fuck that.
We're not taking any,
we're gonna stay right here while this kid's born.
Fuck yeah.
Because it,
it's incurable and your kid develops a tiny head and it's a really creepy find.
They don't even know what else happens because they're,
you know,
the kids that are born from it are only a few years old at this point.
Fucking crazy diseases.
So cruel,
so horrible.
There's a guy named Peter [inaudible] that I,
uh,
interviewed once and he was talking to me about,
um,
it was for my Scifi Shoulda did years back and he was talking to me about,
jungle diseases,
like people that have,
um,
you know,
any sort of,
uh,
infestations of parasites and things like that in the jungle.
And he said,
it is 100% of the people that live there.
They have the 100% of the people that live there have something.
Yeah,
100%.
I went hundred percent.
Does that mean they're living with it or they're suffering from it?
They're living with it.
I mean,
they might be suffering from it,
but one of them was,
um,
this,
uh,
cat parasite toxo plasma.
Have you ever heard of that?
Oh yeah,
we're pregnant.
Women are super dangerous for women to like handle catch it because of it.
You shouldn't touch a litter box or eat any vegetables in France because they
don't.
Uh,
that was my,
my wife went to France when she was pregnant and they said that she couldn't eat
cheese because they don't pasteurize it out correctly in France.
Well,
it makes sense.
They looked at rod stinky fucking cheese down there.
They love that stuff.
They love it.
But it,
um,
it's a weird one because it makes the,
the rat,
when a rat eats it,
ah,
or rat gets it and it's body a rat become sexually attracted to the smell of cat
urine to the point where their dick gets hard and their ball swell up and they
go find the cat and the cat kills him.
And then the cat relays it to people.
And one of the things it does with people's,
it makes him reckless.
So there's a direct,
there's a guy named Dr. Roberts,
a Paul ski at a Stanford Who's done extensive research on Toxoplasma is fucking
fascinating.
Guys get some awesome speeches where he talks about it online.
But one of the things they found when he was working in the Er is a direct
correlation between Toxoplasma and motorcycle accidents.
Like a lot of these people that really,
Yup.
And people that would come in and they would have motorcycle accidents,
they would test them and they'd find out they tested positive for toxo.
50 million people in America tested positive for toxoplasma where he ill.
Yup.
And it,
it affects the way you think.
It affects your judgment and makes you more impulsive,
makes you more aggressive.
And it might even affect women.
It might make women more promiscuous or at least make them more sexually
submissive.
They don't know.
I mean this is just a complete total speculation,
but they think it might be one of the reasons why some South American countries
are very macho and the women are like very sexy.
So why don't we went with cats.
So he's live alone.
I don't think it's the same,
but those cats never leave the house,
so,
so few don't have a cat.
You can't catch this.
No,
you can catch it.
You can catch it from the meat of a cow that eats the cat shit in its,
in its grass like this.
Use a bunch of different ways.
A lot of people,
currently there's probably 50 million people in the country that have this
currently in America.
That's 50 people plus that are infected with this cat parasite called toxo.
Should you get tested for it?
No,
I probably have it for sure.
I'm scared.
I don't want to get tested because you have cats,
right?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm definitely um,
Joey Diaz has 150,000 fucking cats.
Yeah,
he's for sure.
Got It.
All those crazy cat ladies are guarantee they have.
Yeah.
It's a really common thing.
I think in France at one point there was something like 30% of the population
had talkshow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's real.
Well,
we may have feral cats.
Is that a bacteria then?
It's a parasite.
It's some sort of a parasite that actually gets its way into your brain.
Because that's the crazy thing is what,
I forget what percentage of your body weight is bacteria,
but it's not staggering nuts.
Take charge.
15% of your body weight is bacteria.
Yeah.
We're,
we're all up.
See,
I'm full of Shit.
I'm at,
first of all,
find out how many people in America I've toxoplasma before we find that
approximately 30 million.
30 million.
Wow.
It says it's the number on it.
Pull it up.
See if bright 50 million.
See if I,
how do I remember that wrong?
Right.
50 million people in America have talks with 20 of them died.
Oh my God.
I don't think it kills you on motorcycle wreck motorcycles.
Right.
But so Paul [inaudible] was,
um,
he was,
uh,
studying its effects on people and trying to figure out,
like,
they don't really know what it does to people.
There's just this correlation between motorcycle accident.
Then another thing that says up to 60 million people could have it.
So,
hmm.
Okay.
Million people just in America,
Justin America and other countries,
like in some South American countries,
it's a very high and uh,
you know,
it might've been just something that people have been living with forever.
It's just there's some sort of a weird connection that we have to these
organisms.
And in this one,
it,
it rewires the sexual reward system of rodents changes the reward system.
It makes their dick hard for cat piss.
So the day go near the cat,
so they get killed so they can transmit it to people because cats hanging around
with people,
right?
I mean,
assuming that that's the,
the chain of events.
Yeah.
Fucking a man.
Jesus.
I'll give that one to 3% of the body's mass and a 200 pound adults is two to six
pounds of bacteria,
but also play a vital role in human health.
Wow.
Human body contains trillions of microorganisms.
Outnumbering human cells by 10 to one.
Oh Damn.
What?
So 3% of the body's mass,
but they don't outnumber human cells just because of the size,
cause they're small size.
However,
the micro organisms make up only one to 3% of the body's mass.
It doesn't make as much as the mass,
but you are outnumbered.
Human cells are outnumbered 10 to one.
That's like,
if there's every one rat for every person on a ship and there's,
you know,
10 people
think of that.
Hmm.
I mean,
that's a fucking infested rat filled ship.
Well,
the,
some of the bacteria is good.
Some of it is.
Yeah.
But I'm just saying you're mostly rats.
See,
like what is that a ship of people?
Well,
some people on it.
Yeah.
Right.
It's mostly rats.
I mean,
it's mostly rap fucking rat ship.
Yeah.
It's a,
we are,
I mean,
if you had a hundred people,
a thousand rats on a ship,
which say that's a ship full of people or ship full of rats.
It's a shippable Uracil to pour a bunch of poor fuckers trying to get some
sleep.
Yeah.
We're just bags of bacteria.
We're bags of bacteria and we don't understand a lot of it.
Cause it is,
it's so fucking small and it's mysterious.
Yeah.